arkansas republican senator tom cotton
joins me now
senator first of all i just want to get
your top-line reaction to these numbers
that we're hearing
harris these are astonishing surges in
illegal immigration at our border as we
heard from bill there was a record in
2021 the highest number of illegal
immigrants encountered at our border in
22 years and those are just the ones
that the border patrol encountered not
the ones that got away but apparently
joe biden is not resting on his laurels
after setting the record last year he
wants to break his own record in 2022 we
might have more than two million
illegals crossing our border this year
and as you said harris those are not
people seeking asylum from persecution
they're coming for one reason that's
because they know that joe biden will
let them in that's dangerous for america
because many times they're smuggling in
drugs as well there are gang members or
other kinds of criminals that are
crossing our uncontrolled border yeah i
mean they know that they can mix in with
the pack
and we can't catch them all and without
title 42 i don't know how much covid
testing we're doing anyway
uh but we we're at a real real
standpoint now in terms of trying to
slow that disease down that virus down
if this onslaught is coming yeah and
it's amazing i mean only a blinkered
ideologue like joe biden and the
democratic party could think there's no
pandemic at our border with no cases
coming across into our country yet they
still insist that american toddlers wear
masks when they travel on airplanes and
trains oh and there's so much hypocrisy
in all of it
so much it's what they want politically
all right speaking of covet let's get to
this dr anthony fauci now warning that
people should be prepared
for renewed coveted restrictions as we
see a new variant emerge and cases on
the rise again let's watch
i don't want to use the word lockdowns
that has a charged element to it but i
believe that we must keep our eye on
the pattern of what we're seeing with
infections we should be prepared
and flexible enough to pivot
towards going back at least temporarily
to a more rigid type of restriction such
as requiring masks indoor
he should be
prepared and nimble enough to get to the
border and talk about those things a new
national poll finds a majority of
americans do not support a return to
masking and social distancing guidance a
whopping 62 percent say they oppose it
but the party breakdown shows a
different story 62 percent of democrats
support bringing back those restrictions
very few republicans
want to see that
meanwhile 21 states are now suing the
biden administration over mass mandates
on public transportation senator tommy
tuberville with this
the match that people are wearing in
airports and schools they don't work
they don't help and so
it's just it's uh it's control you know
that it's controlled by the federal
government they want to control
everything you do
senator cotton what do you say to the
american people right now i mean we know
a majority of them are still just you
know out of obligation wearing their
mouths kind of half down their nose
their cloth masks i mean tuberville has
such a good point what they are choosing
to do wouldn't help anyway
well the american people are very
sensible about these things uh they have
what i think is the correct risk
calculus they recognize that coronavirus
is now going to be endemic in our
society meaning it's always going to be
present and we'll have to deal with it
in the same way we deal with the common
cold and the flu and other diseases but
we cannot continue to upend our life or
as tony fauci says be prepared for the
next surge in which he's going to tell
us that we all have to wear masks and
stay out of public places and shut down
our businesses
tony vouchers should be prepared to
answer
questions to the american people about
why he lied to congress and about how
his agency funded those labs in woohand
when republicans take back congress this
fall because that's exactly where he's
going to be in january
all right let's move to this bank
records reportedly show hunter biden
received 100 thousand dollars from a
chinese energy firm not that long ago
2017. republican senators ron johnson
chuck grassley revealing the financial
documents on the senate floor this week
there is no
middleman in this transaction
this is one hundred thousand dollars
from what is effectively
an arm of the communist chinese
government
direct
to hunter biden to the liberal media
and my democrat colleagues is this
official bank document
russian
disinformation
florida congressman matt gates also
entered a copy of hunter's abandoned
laptop hard drive into the congressional
records republicans promise an
investigation if they retake the
majority let's pause there to my team i
want to go back to senator cotton
your reaction
yeah here speaking of people who should
be prepared to testify to congress in
january when republicans are in charge
hunter biden will be at the top of that
list as will james fiden the president's
brother and devin archer their business
partner the media and big tech
suppressed this story in october of 2020
because they were afraid it would hurt
joe biden's electoral chances they now
acknowledge it to be true those are some
other good executives that might want to
come in to testify about what they did
to call this as chuck grassley just said
russian disinformation when in reality
it was always clear that it was true
from the beginning hunter biden has been
feathering the biden family nest for
decades off of his father's public
service and the american people deserve
answers about exactly what was happening
and for all we know what could be
happening right now so senator real
quickly before i let you go because i've
made the point many times the reason why
we care about the story is is
nonpartisan and as a journalist you
always want to be able to say that you
found every way possible
to see the facts around vulnerability
with the man who leads the nation and
arguably the free world
this is a conduit of vulnerability if
hunter biden is doing what
well if he's accepting six and seven and
uh eight figure payoffs from foreign
oligarchs and governments as he has for
years
harris for his almost as long as hunter
biden has been a grown adult he has been
trading off of his father's public
service first in the senate then as vice
president do we really think that that
bird is going to change his feathers
when his father gets the biggest job of
all
you could say the same thing for joe
biden's brother as well the american
people deserve answers to this
senator tom cotton great state of
arkansas thank you for being in focus
thank you hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now